Look, the bottom line here, Meg, is that
you're just taking your own problems out on
everyone else.
Oh, my problems?
Oh, I see. Is this coming from my role model
mother? The shoplifter, the drug addict, the
porn star, the whore who let Gene Simmons and
Bill Clinton go to town on her?
Oh, so what?
All those things are behind me now. I'm a
better person now because of those experiences.
Are you are you a better person?
What's your point, Meg?
My point is that with all the irresponsible,
reckless, idiotic behavior in your past, that
somehow, somehow you have the nerve, the
arrogance to consistently and ruthlessly
point out my shortcomings.
All right. Well, fine. Okay. I'm not the
perfect mother. Who is?
Oh, not only are you not the perfect mother,
you're the furthest thing from.
From the moment you gave birth to me, I had to trust
you. I had no choice. I needed you to protect
me from the world, to- to be my guide. To help
me navigate the difficult, confusing and
vulnerable journey to becoming a person.
You have done none of those things.
You're my mother, and you took a child's trust and
smashed it into bits in a 17 year long
mission to destroy something that you killed
a long time ago. And honestly, when I turn
18, I don't know that I ever want to see you
again.
Oh, wow. Everybody's already tweeting "Stewie
just said that".
Oh.
You're right.
You're right. I'm a terrible mother. I'm so
sorry. I'm so, so sorry.
Meg, can you ever forgive me?
Oh, God.
And you never let Dad stir the paint anymore.
Whatever that means.
I didn't know you knew that, Meg, but I'm
glad you brought it up.